[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué emoción es estar aquí
vamos a cerrar los ojos un momento y
quiero que imaginen conmigo un relato un
relato que puede ser de ciencia ficción
una mañana nos despertamos abrimos los
ojos
sacamos el teléfono celular
y empezamos
a darnos cuenta que en las redes
sociales las cadenas de televisión y los
noticieros de radio de la mañana están
hablando de una tormenta solar
[Música]
a las 6 35 m el servicio de clima
espacial reporta que el satélite goes de
la noaa acaba de detectar una explosión
en la superficie del sol la cual es la
más intensa que hemos registrado en los
últimos 30 años esta observación fue
corroborada por dos misiones de la nasa
el satélite sd o fotografió el lugar en
donde ocurrió la explosión y el
telescopio de la nave sojo captó una
gigantesca nube que fue inyectada en
dirección hacia el planeta y se dirige
hacia nosotros a más de 3000 kilómetros
por segundo
[Música]
los servicios de clima espacial están en
estado de alerta y en comunicaciones e
intercambiando datos y también están
comunicándose con los sistemas
nacionales de protección civil
hay el temor de que la nube que se está
aproximando hacia la tierra tenga las
características para generar el mayor
daño posible esto es que se trate de la
tormenta solar perfecta
[Música]
se empiezan a reportar fallas de
satélites y sistemas de
telecomunicaciones 15 horas después del
estallido a las 11 30 de la noche
el satélite discover de la nova que se
encuentra justo en la línea entre el sol
y la tierra capta la nube que se dirige
hacia la tierra
[Música]
se confirma el peor escenario posible
tiene las características de tormenta
solar perfecta se le notifica al
presidente
diez minutos después la nube pasa e
impacta el campo magnético de la tierra
comienza un despliegue de auroras
boreales que cubre prácticamente todo el
planeta
[Música]
se reportan fallas en muchos sistemas
tecnológicos
y un par de horas después después de la
medianoche
nos enteramos de colapsos de la de las
redes de energía eléctrica en muchas
partes del mundo ya no hay internet
ya no hay operaciones bancarias
electrónicas
los sistemas de distribución de agua y
de combustible han colapsado estamos
ante un apagón global
[Música]
el teléfono celular que habíamos
utilizado
en la mañana hace unas horas
ahora ya no funcionan
pero bueno
[Música]
esto es un
es solo un relato de ciencia ficción
o no
este escenario catastrófico esta
secuencia de eventos
es un escenario real que nos preocupa
con mucha seriedad a los científicos que
nos dedicamos a estudiar la actividad
del sol y sus efectos sobre la tierra
pero de dónde surge todo esto como como
es posible
esto surge de una estrella de nuestra
estrella de esa estrella de los más de
100 mil millones de estrellas que
existen tan solo en nuestra galaxia esta
es la más importante la vital para
nosotros
es un astro fabuloso extraordinario
lleno de belleza y de complejidad no hay
civilización en la historia de la
humanidad que no le haya rendido tributo
al sol
esta representación que traigo del sol
tiene un diámetro aproximadamente de un
metro
en esta escala la tierra
me diría menos de un centímetro
esto significa que dentro de esta
hipotética esfera del sol caben más de
un millón de tierras adentro
la distancia del sol a la tierra son 150
millones de kilómetros en esta
representación donde el la esfera del
sol tiene un diámetro de un metro esta
distancia sería algo así como 100 metros
un poco más de 100 metros o sea que en
una cancha profesional de fútbol el sol
estaría en una portería y la tierra
midiendo menos de un centímetro de
diámetro estaría en la otra
la superficie del sol en ocasiones se ve
como como esta se ve lisa sin embargo
hay otras ocasiones en que la superficie
del sol
presenta estas regiones oscuras estas
regiones oscuras le llamamos manchas
solares
y son muy importantes porque son
concentraciones de campo magnético muy
intenso en la superficie del sol las
manchas solares tienen un comportamiento
cíclico que dura aproximadamente 11 años
a qué me refiero
en momentos como ahora en 2019 el sol
prácticamente no tiene manchas
y en su superficie ocurre en muy pocas
explosiones y éstas son muy moderadas
sin embargo
poco a poco en 5 o 6 años vamos a
alcanzar el siguiente máximo del ciclo y
esto significa que el sol va a tener
manchas muy grandes y van a estar
ocurriendo tormentas solares muy
intensas y éstas pueden incluso ocurrir
varias por vía
y después el sol empezará otra vez a
perder sus manchas
y llegaremos al siguiente mínimo en el
pero bueno qué pasa con las manchas
solares concentran campos magnéticos y
como el sol está rotando y tarda 27 días
en dar una vuelta este movimiento
empieza
a torcer las manchas las empieza a
pensar y en ocasiones acumulan
suficiente energía como para producir
explosiones cuando ocurre una tormenta
solar hay un estallido de luz muy
intenso que dura sólo unos minutos en la
región donde ocurrió la explosión hay un
calentamiento y se empiezan a acelerar
partículas que sería que viajan al
espacio y de ahí se desprenden en
ocasiones gigantescas nubes que son
inyectadas hacia el espacio
algunas de estas nubes pasan por donde
está la tierra
nuestro planeta tiene un sistema
protector
el campo magnético de la tierra es una
forma una coraza que impide que las
partículas que vienen del sol penetren
en la atmósfera de la tierra
esta coraza ha sido muy importante para
el desarrollo de la vida en nuestro
planeta sin embargo esta coraza no es
infalible
y se puede romper en ocasiones el campo
magnético que viene con la nube solar se
reconecta con el campo magnético de la
tierra se abre una compuerta a través de
la cual empiezan a entrar partículas que
vienen del sol a la atmósfera de la
tierra y esta apertura dura varias horas
estas partículas que entran forman las
auroras boreales
pero también desencadenan una serie de
fenómenos físicos que afectan sistemas
tecnológicos indispensables
para la civilización moderna
satélites
navegación aérea sistemas de
telecomunicaciones
sistemas de posicionamiento global y las
redes de generación y distribución de
energía eléctrica todas estas
tecnologías son vulnerables a las
tormentas solares
bueno pero una tormenta solar perfecta
no ha ocurrido todavía o sí y si ocurrió
porque no nos hemos enterado de un
colapso tecnológico producido por una
tormenta solar
no hay que olvidar que el sol tiene
cinco mil millones de años
y lees y nuestro planeta ha sufrido los
estragos de las tormentas solares a
través de toda su historia
sin embargo el más reciente ocurrió hace
160 años y se conoce como el evento
carrington
el primero de septiembre de 1859 el
astrónomo británico richard carrington
así a sus observaciones diarias del sol
como lo hacía todos los días durante
varios meses para estudiar la evolución
y los cambios de las manchas solares en
la superficie del sol
esa mañana como a las 11 de la mañana
richard carrington proyectaba la imagen
del sol que captaba con su telescopio
sobre una hoja de papel y sobre esa hoja
se ponía a dibujar el contorno de la
mancha solar
cuando estaba terminando su dibujo de
repente vi un destello de luz que nunca
antes había visto y nunca más volvería a
ver este destello de luz duró cinco
minutos
sin saberlo richard carrington estaba
observando por primera vez una tormenta
solar
17 horas después de la observación de
richard carrington comenzó el despliegue
de auroras boreales más intenso y
extenso que tenemos registrado en la
historia moderna del planeta
el 2 de septiembre de 1859 59 una nube
una aurora boreal cubrió todo el planeta
y fue inclusive vista en méxico tenemos
registros históricos de al menos siete
sitios donde se observó este asombroso
fenómeno el cielo nocturno se iluminó de
rojo
aquí es importante aclarar que cuando
ocurrió el evento carrington no hay
reportes de fallecimientos súbitos o
afectaciones a seres vivos
qué pasa pues los 150 millones de
kilómetros de nuestra atmósfera y la
corta duración del estallido nos
protegen
las tormentas solares no tienen efectos
directos sobre la salud de los seres
vivos
pero tampoco escuchamos de un colapso
tecnológico con el evento carrington
pero la razón de esto es relativamente
sencilla en el siglo 19 no había aviones
no había satélites no había redes
sociales no había sistemas de
telecomunicaciones no había redes de
generación y distribución de energía
eléctrica ninguna de esas tecnologías se
había inventado todavía
más recientemente en julio de 2012 la
nave espacial de la nasa estéreo que se
encontraba en ese momento lejos de la
tierra
detecto el paso de una nube que tenía
las características de una tormenta
solar perfecta
la nave estaba muy lejos de la tierra y
afortunadamente nada le pasó al planeta
nos salvamos
más recientemente en septiembre de 2017
una mancha solar empezó a producir
tormentas solares intensas esto en
méxico coincidió con la ocurrencia de
huracanes y de sismos
en redes sociales se empezó a circular
noticias falsas sobre que las tormentas
solares producían terremotos en mexico
el sistema el servicio sismológico el
servicio de clima espacial y el sistema
nacional de protección civil tuvieron
que salir a medios al revés aclarar que
esto no es verdad que no hay una
relación entre estos dos fenómenos
pero
qué podemos hacer nosotros ante las
tormentas solares que debe hacer el
gobierno
nosotros
nada
este es un evento global que amenaza la
seguridad nacional de todos los países
comités técnicos de expertos de las
naciones unidas recomiendan la
colaboración internacional en el estudio
y el monitoreo del sol y el desarrollo
de protocolos
para incrementar la resiliencia de
nuestras tecnologías ante estos
fenómenos naturales
varios países han desarrollado ya planes
nacionales
a incrementar su protección y su
reacción ante estos fenómenos en méjico
en julio de 2014 se modificó la ley
general de protección civil
y esta ya incluye a las tormentas
solares como una amenaza a la seguridad
nacional
se creó el servicio de clima espacial se
creó el laboratorio nacional de clima
espacial y estamos trabajando con el
sistema nacional de protección civil en
el desarrollo de protocolos de
prevención y de reacción ante estos
fenómenos
que hemos aprendido hoy
las tormentas solares son un fenómeno
natural que puede afectar la seguridad
de todos los países
tenemos que desarrollar
una estrategia y el gobierno debe
invertir en investigación científica
y monitoreo y en el desarrollo de
protocolos para incrementar nuestra
residencia
cuando ocurren fenómenos naturales que
pueden ocasionar desastres es muy
importante estar bien informados
como en el caso de los sismos y los
huracanes no sabemos cuándo va a ocurrir
la próxima tormenta solar perfecta puede
ser en 100 años
o puede ser tan sólo en cinco o seis no
lo sabemos lo que sí sabemos es que va a
ocurrir y que tenemos que estar
prevenidos
cuando ocurra
un fenómeno natural que ocasiona un
desastre es muy importante no difundir
información falsa
tener siempre buena información
la mejor prevención
empieza por estar bien informado
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]